when you love someone they say you said
I'm free that ain't gonna work for me
you did it don't be able to do your show
the moment Blake Shelton and Gwen
Stefani are giving fans a
behind-the-scenes look at their romantic
duet nobody but you which was actually
recorded at Blake's lake house in
Oklahoma so Blake revealed that he had
to do eight or nine takes of the song
before he nailed it
and once he had his part down Gwen flew
to Oklahoma on her day off from her
headlining Las Vegas show to add her
parts we timed it to where Wynn works on
Wednesday Fridays Saturdays in Las Vegas
so I was able to get her to the house on
the Thursday on her day off in Oklahoma
to record her part of nobody but you huh
what is that
I almost got my screen saver that's me
pimpin out you know I wanted those my
whole life you warned my eyebrows on the
other hand actually worked out really
good because her voice is in such great
shape right now because she's working so
much out there I don't know that I've
ever heard her singing any better than
she is right now it's just a super
strong voice right now
and Blake didn't stop craving his
girlfriend adding how impressed he and
his team were with Gwen focus I'm still
learning when it comes to recording with
with Gwen we won't record it literally a
handful of songs together but the thing
that I think that I'm blown away by with
Gwen is just how hard she works when she
gets in the studio she wants she's not
willing to take anything less than then
greatness you know and she's willing to
put in the work I mean I don't care if
it means she's got to get in there and
sing till she completely loses her voice
[Music]
I don't think when those how great of a
vocalist she really is and even Scott
Hendricks you know there was a time or
two and we when we've recorded her that
you know she can't even hear what he's
saying he'll just lean back and go wow
of course Gwen returned the compliment
revealing that I hope he's been a
fantasy to sing on one of Blake's songs
just so you know and for you to know not
even a dream of mine to be on Blake
Shelton song but fantasy would be more
like better than a dream because if
fantasies completely unlikely like a
dream can come true fantasies are just
something you just make up in your brain
so for you to ask me to be on a song
it's like can I ask you a question yeah
are you intoxicated
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
so what did you think of this
behind-the-scenes look and do you want
to see this couple collaborate with each
other more often let me know in the
comments below